[Music]
hello everyone
so we'll continue from exactly where we
left off in the previous lecture
we were about to uh substitute the
expressions of
epsilon x6 epsilon yy and epsilon xy
from from the previous page
where we had obtained this uh the
simplified versions in terms of the
sigma xx and the
sigma yy after eliminating the sigma zz
using this relation
uh so we'll do that
right away so del square
uh del square del y
square epsilon x x you see
uh here epsilon x x contains the one
plus
nu by e and that is a constant that may
come out of this second order derivative
with respect to y
will have 1 plus nu by e starting
outside
l square del y square
and the rest of it or whatever is inside
1 minus new sigma xx
minus nu sigma yy
right let me just write that a little
bit better
okay
similarly for epsilon yy we use this
relation here from the previous page
again the 1 plus nu by e goes outside
and we have del square del x square
1 minus nu sigma yy
minus nu sigma xx
and on the right hand side i have for my
epsilon xy
this expression in terms of sigma xy
again the 1 plus nu by e comes outside
of the second order derivative
del square del del x del y
of sigma x y this time now you see
that on in each of the terms
this one plus mu by e is common so that
can be cancelled out
and what we have left uh
so here this one minus nu sigma x6
what we'll do is
we will uh so this is associated with a
del square del y square
now what we want to do is uh
introduce another term involving the
sigma xx
but which will have a derivative uh a
second-order derivative with respect to
x so if we do that
okay so and with the same coefficient 1
minus nu
so what we basically want to do is
uh add a 1 minus mu
del square sigma x x del x square
and we also want to subtract that out
okay so let's see what happens if we do
that
okay so
from this one from this first term
what we'll obtain is
l square del x square
plus del square del y square
okay getting this laplacian out
that was that is the motivation of
introducing
a term like 1 minus nu del square sigma
xx
del x square so we get that
now uh let us
write whatever is remaining in this one
okay so let's write that we are not
manipulating that term
let it remain as it is now just like we
had manipulated this one
let us manipulate this one also what
we're going to add this time
is 1 plus nu del square sigma yy
del y square because our motivation is
to obtain a laplacian
term so when we do that
we obtain l squared
del x square plus del square
del y square operating on
sigma yy and we write
this remaining term as it is
however we are far from done because we
we have not yet adjusted the artificial
adding of this term we need to subtract
that out
now it is adjusted this artificial
addition of this term
that is adjusted by this term similarly
we had artificially adjust
added this 1 plus 1 minus nu times
del square sigma yy del y square and we
need to subtract that out also
now we are done on the left hand side on
the right hand side what we'll have
is this l square sigma x y
del x del y all right
now let's see if we can have any
simplification
uh you note
this term has a minus nu
and this is a similar sort of term in
terms of the
second order derivative with respect to
y but it has
basically a plus nu sitting in front so
what will
basically remain from here is a minus
del square sigma yy
del y square now let us consider next
this term along with this term here we
have a minus mu del square sigma x x del
x
square but here we have a plus nu del
square sigma x 6 del x
square so overall this gets
substantially
simplified now in this next step we are
actually going to write this one as a
laplacian
of sigma x6 and this has a laplacian of
sigma xx
so overall that one minus nu
times the laplacian that gets uh taken
as common
so overall we have this nice compact
term
from here and from here
this one as i said this gets
uh simplified over here and this gets
simplified over here
so what we have basically is
minus del square sigma xx del x
square and from here we have minus
l square sigma yy del
y square that is equal to l squared
sigma x y del x
del y i think i missed this 2 here so
that should go here
and that should go here all right
now uh just as i was uh
as i had been proceeding earlier uh
by numbering the equations let me do
that also here otherwise it's going to
be a jumbled mess
uh to refer to it once
we have more number of equations so let
me call this
since we are continuing in the same
document let me just take a look at
the last number of last numbered
equation
so we had this as 10
let's say uh
this is 12 so let's say this is 13
and let's say this by harmonic equation
that's that is our equation number 14.
similarly uh
let's say this is our equation
uh actually i would like to
start the numbering all over again
otherwise uh it's going to be
a huge uh very large
number in the equation in the equation
number
so if you don't mind even though i'm
working in the same document and
do this but i don't need to number this
one
let me call this as my number one
equation here
this is my number two
this will be number three this is number
four
i don't need these two and what i'm
basically doing here
is uh
this is my equation number five
in order to obtain these equations this
this term
what i'm doing is to use
equation 1 equation 2
question 1 2 and equation four
in equation five that's what i did
okay so after i've obtained this
uh what i'll say is that this is my
equation number six all right now i'm
happy
now uh just like as i had proceeded
in the case of the plane stress paradigm
what i will do uh in order to simplify
these equations and also to take into
account the
stress equilibrium equations i
considered these
two equations uh or
these these stress equilibrium equations
but
considering the body force terms okay
so here just for the sake of discussing
it as a side note i had not considered
the body first term but this time i will
so let me quickly go to the next page
and consider
equation with the body force term
please note that i am no longer on the
basis of that earlier discussion i am no
longer
writing the stress components involving
the z
now my motivation is to uh
somehow arrive at terms involving the
second order derivatives of sigma xx and
sigma yy with x and y respectively
so i differentiate this first one just
like as i had done in the case of the
plane stress formulation
with respect to x so i obtain del square
sigma x x
del x square plus l square
sigma x y del x del y
and that is minus of del fx
del x the second one
i differentiate with respect to y so
that i obtain del square sigma xy
del y del x
plus del square sigma yy
del y square that is equal to
minus del fy
ly so let's call these two equations
equation number seven and eight
and again i add up seven and eight
to obtain l squared
sigma xx del x square
plus l square sigma yy
del y square plus
i add these two together because
again the continuity of second order
derivatives
uh so the order of the derivatives do
not matter
l square sigma x y del x
del y that is equal to minus of
del fx del x
plus del f
y del y
all right let's call this equation 9.
now i want to use equation 9 back in
my equation number 6 okay so
this term remains as it is and i'm going
to substitute
this particular expression from this
equation number nine
so use nine in
x so
this is one minus nu
del square sigma xx
plus sigma yy
this one i take the minus common
and this is
[Music]
if i just go back here and
write like this so whatever is within
the bracket
that can be written from equation number
nine
like this
sorry on the right hand side i do not
have a zero rather i have
this term involving the sigma x y
twice del square sigma x y
del x l y
what i obtained from here uh if you note
that this minus in this minus is a plus
so this term is cancelling with this so
overall what i'm going to get is this 1
minus mu
laplacian of sigma xx plus sigma yy
that is equal to so this minus and this
minus is a plus on the left-hand side if
i transpose these two terms on the
right-hand side
i will get minus of
within bracket del f x del x plus
l f y del y
okay now let's call this equation number
10
now this is the this is the point
uh there's the corresponding uh in the
in the planes risk
condition and the plane stress
formulation at this corresponding point
what we had done
was to introduce the eddy stress
function
okay so uh we'll do that again
by considering the stress equilibrium
equations again so we go back to these
two equations
and consider them again so
consider the stress equilibrium
equations again
we consider them again but
with conservative body forces so just
like in the case of
the plane stress
and when we have conservative body
forces they can be written
in terms of of a scalar potential
so what we basically have
is uh this fx term being written
in terms of a minus del p del x so we
can
we can write this f f x
as a minus del p del x
so that what we basically have is this
del del x of
sigma x x minus of uh
v minus x minus v
plus del sigma x y
del y is equal to 0 and similarly from
from the from the second of the stress
equilibrium equations
we have this minus del b del y term
so that overall this can be written
as del sigma x y del x plus
del del y of sigma yy
minus v equal to zero
now these two equations okay uh
without going into any more detailed
discussions these uh based on what we
have already discussed it's exactly the
same way
uh the same logic so these two equations
will be identically satisfied
okay if we use sigma xx minus v
is equal to del square phi
del y square sigma yy
minus v is equal to del square phi
del x square and sigma x y
is equal to minus del square phi del x
del y i repeat when we use these
particular forms
back here these two equations are
identically satisfied
so if we can use these equations back in
equation number 10
okay so use this use
in equation number 10 so what we obtain
then
so we come here and look at it 1 minus
nu del square
v plus del square phi
del y squared plus
v plus del square phi del x
squared this is from sigma xx and these
two are from sigma yy
so on the right hand side we have the
minus
of del fx del x so that
f x will be substituted by minus del p
del x so overall we
have a del square v del x square and
here we'll have a del square v del y
square
and please note here that this is a
twice v so
this is 2 into 1 minus nu of
l squared p plus
1 minus nu and this is
a laplacian but there is already a
laplacian outside
we have to take care of that
on the right hand side this is simply
the laplacian overview
okay so if we go to the next
page uh we just have to take care of
taking this thing appropriately to the
the right hand side
and what we'll obtain is
this so
this one remains as it is this one minus
nu
we have the by harmonic operator
appearing again
and this is one minus
1 minus 2 because this is a 2 here
and this minus 2 nu becomes f plus 2 nu
and we have this laplacian of v
so
what we have basically is this del 4
pi is equal to
minus 1 minus twice
nu divided by 1 minus nu
l square v so this final form
of the plane strain formulation uh
let us compare this quickly with what we
obtained at the end
of the plane stress formulation if you
go back a few pages
we'll see that this final equation the
bi-harmonic
of pi the bioharmonic uh
operator operating on phi that is equal
to minus of one minus nu del square v
okay so and now
everything is the same except this
coefficient
okay so this is from the plane strain
formulation
let's not forget that
okay and what we had obtained earlier
earlier for plane stress
for plane stress we had obtained
minus of 1 minus nu del square
t
again this equation number 13
uh on the previous page
all right so just like as we had talked
about
the special case that when body forces
vanish
and body forces vanish
or del square v is equal to zero
then we simply have the by harmonic
equation
okay so this is true
or clean string
as it was
for paint stress
okay so this should tell us the
the great importance of this by harmonic
equation
okay and it is based on this that we are
going to solve
a lot of the problems so with this we
end this part of the
lecture and we'll see various ways in
which we can proceed towards the
solution of this
i harmonic equation in the subsequent
lectures
all right thank you very much